the question is as on the order papers
many of that opinions say i i
of the country no
i think the eyes have it
the eyes have it
point of order paula barker
deputy speaker mr deputy speaker uh
julia and her daughter and it goes
through let's speak to our deputy
political editor sam coats who's
standing by in central lobby uh sam what
happens now well it's been a very long
four hours the commons have just on the
nod which means agreed without a vote
that boris johnson will now face a third
inquiry this one will be held by a
committee called the privileges
committee it's got four tories one labor
and one smp member on it and that
inquiry which won't take place for
several weeks until after the police
have concluded their work and sue grey
has included hers uh we'll look at
whether or not boris johnson lied to
parliament there's a list of different
things the prime minister said in the
last few weeks and months about whether
or not rules were broken at the heart of
government during the pandemic now a
committee of mps will judge whether or
not what he said then amounts to a lie
of course if you knowingly mislead
parliament according to the ministerial
uh guidebooks you have to resign but
really sarah jane the significance of
today is a little bit more
in what didn't happen as much as what
did
that's because as recently as eight
o'clock last night the conservatives
wanted to fight this attempt to have a
third inquiry into boris johnson but
when the tory whips looked around this
morning before that debate began at 11
30 they sniffed the wind talked to
colleagues took the temperature and
realized that if they put the attempt to
block this third
investigation to the vote then there
simply might not be enough tories coming
through behind ministers in the lobbies
uh to defend the prime minister at this
time far too many people they worried
would give the impression of sitting in
their hands waiting to see how this was
going to play out and it was that
unwillingness of tory mps we all believe
tory and bees believe
meant that the government pulled their
attempt to block this third probe and
that's why it's going ahead and that was
all before 11 30. once the debate
actually was underway you heard a couple
of quite significant interventions from
tory mps william rag
territory select committee chair and
then steve baker became the 15th and
16th people inside the conservative
parliamentary party to say the boris
johnson can't take them into the next
election steve baker a prominent figure
played a big role defenestrating theresa
may boris johnson's predecessor saying
that boris johnson should go
now steve baker backed boris johnson on
tuesday so that's quite a rapid u-turn
and his u-turn reflect a broader more
worrying i think change in the mood
slight change in the mood
attitude amongst tory mps towards boris
johnson i've been talking this afternoon
to tory mps from across the party from
the one nation more moderate wing
through to those on the tory right and
they all agree boris johnson's position
through the events of today is weaker
than it was just 48 hours ago when he
gave that statement to parliament
defending the fact that he'd been fined
by the police for breaking the rules on
the 19th of june 2020 and i think that
there's this sense of some of the
authority some of the power some of the
support in the prime minister amongst
tory mps who does he keep saying or the
judge during execution of a touring
prime minister some of that support has
waned now it's too early to say what
will happen it's too early to call time
on boris johnson's premiership the one
conclusion i think we can draw from
today and downing wheat downing street's
unwillingness to push to a fight this
business of a third inquiry is that they
are just worried about what tory mps
really actually think about what boris
johnson did
okay sam thank you uh that update the
motion by labor uh to
see the prime minister go before a
committee a standards committee has been
nodded through there wasn't a vote it
has gone through
more on that throughout the day here on
sky news